would all alien civilizations have an
evolutionary process
on a planet
so like that's one of the almost it's
almost the definition of life to create
all those memories you have to
have something like a change in time
yeah and but there has to be selection
um that's like an efficient there's no
other way to do it no well never say
never because students say that's the
part that depresses me though going back
to like I don't know the earlier
discussion on violence and things like
and I I don't know where somebody was
tweeting about this recently but like
you know how much stuff had to die maybe
it was you yeah uh yeah so yes we were
talking we're talking about life yeah
and uh I guess
a lot of murder had to occur right so
selections had to be weeded out right so
well we can celebrate that death makes
way too long yeah I mean it and also you
know one of the most interesting
features of major Extinction events in
the history of our planet is how much
novelty emerged immediately after right
so and of course you know a lot of
people make arguments we wouldn't be
here if the dinosaurs didn't go extinct
so
um in some ways
we can attribute our existence to all of
that but I guess I was just wondering
sort of like if I was going to build a
universe myself
in the most optimistic way would I
retain that feature but it does seem to
be you have to I mean I think we're I
think we're probably being over
um anthropomorphizing I remember
watching uh the blue I think it was the
Blue Planet David Attenborough was
showing these seals and because of
climate change some seals were falling
off a cliff and how tragic it was I was
like I'm saying my son
that's pretty cool like look at look at
those ones down there they've obviously
got some kind of mutations some and
they're not doing that Darth thing and
so that that that poor Gene will be
weeded out of course at the individual
level it looks tragic and of course as
human beings have the ability to
abstract and we empathize we don't want
to cause suffering on other human beings
and we should retain that but we
shouldn't look back in time and say you
know how many butterflies had to die
if you think about the caterpillar
become the Chrysalis and the Butterfly
getting out how many if that suffering
we call it suffering if that process of
pruning had not occurred we have no
butterflies so none of the Butterfly
Beauty in the world without all that
pruning so pruning is required but we
shouldn't Amber from morphise and feel
sorry for the biological entities
because that's that seems to be a
backwards way of looking at it what we
should do is Project forward and maybe
think about what values we have across
our species and our ecosystem and our
fellow human beings you know you know
now that we know that animals suffer at
some level
think about Humane farming when we find
that plants can in fact our conscious
and can think and have pain then we'll
do
um Humane gardening until that point we
won't do it right I like this
um famous chemist endorses the Majestic
nature of murder that's the title
um I didn't say that but anyway well I
just insert I have a hard time with it
though I think we should put it it's
kind of but it it's the reality of it's
the reality of it is beautiful
um you know there's an Instagram account
called Nature's metal
and I I keep following and unfollowing
it because I can't handle it for
prolonged periods of time we evolve
together you dialogue
yeah we all together well you die alone
so you live alone too it's a Gatsby
thing I don't know we evolved together
we're still together the together is the
murderer the population
respect the murder my romantic vision of
it to try to make me happy Sarah instead
of sad Sarah
um I talk in third person when I think
very abstractly sorry
um is um you know like like this whole
like you know the like certain things
can co-exist so the universe is trying
to maximize existence but there's some
things that just
aren't
the most productive productive
trajectory together but it doesn't mean
that they don't exist on another
timeline or another chain somewhere else
like I like and maybe you would call
that like then some kind of Multiverse
or things but what am I saying I think
you can't I just you can't go down I'm
just making stuff up no you're not
feeling better I don't understand it is
illogical and we need no I know I know
if you look at bacteria if you look at
virus I mean just just the number of
organisms that are constantly looking at
bacteria they're just dying non-stop
right Slaughter right so when this goes
back to the conversation about God I
mean like there's the whole thing about
like why is the universe enable
suffering individuals don't exist right
in individual so for this I think if you
think about life as an entity on earth
right
let's just let's just go back a second I
mean I like to I'll be ludicrous for a
second I don't exist you don't exist
right
um but you but the actions you do the
product of evolution exists right the
objects you create exist
quantitatively in the real world if you
then understand life on Earth or alien
life or any life in the universe there's
this integrated entity where you need
you need cells in your body to die
otherwise you just get really big and
you won't be able to walk around right
so you know you do yeah yeah so yeah so
yeah so I I think the patterns that
persist not the physical thing and of
course we you know we have we have we
place immense values on fellow human
beings and I'm just Majestic Professor
does like other individual human beings
now you're talking in third person too I
know it happens right so death would you
say I mean because you said evolution is
a fundamental part of um life so death
is a fundamental part of life yeah
it might right now it may not be in the
future we might hack some aspects of
death because and will evolve in
different ways